hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with our
second blind review of one black clover
which will be covering the second dark
which i believe has a name this time so
good on it it's called the dungeon
exploration arc and it was quite an
interesting experience actually the arc
begins in such a basic place with a
whole ton of shonen cliches but by the
end we have this really tightly packed
bit of story where nothing seems wasted
no character no action no dialogue is
extraneous and it builds up to explore
one core idea which is family it was all
really well done for the most part
although i do have
some issues of course but before that
please do let me know if you are
enjoying these videos by clicking the
shiny red subscribe button which will
allow you to receive
maybe regular black clover content and
also shove a like on this here video
because out of your spoilers i probably
won't be looking at comments so those
are the two ways that you can let me
know if you want more of me reviewing
the yelling child but the premise of
this arc is pretty mind-blowingly simple
it's basically we finished the game
tutorial and now we're off all on our
own into our first dungeon hurrah which
is actually a dungeon of pretty
monumental importance because this short
secondary arc is quite complicated quite
quickly because there are actually three
factions interested in this newly
discovered location one of which is the
black bulls featuring aston noel and the
previously unexplored luck but we also
have the golden dawn involved in another
trio with juno and
two others but in addition to that we
also have a faction from a rival country
the diamond
kingdom which present our two main
antagonists and from there it's just a
race to see who can get to the dungeon
treasure first with plenty of conflict
between each of the groups it's a very
straightforward story that mostly
derives its depth from character
interactions and flashbacks lots and
lots of flashbacks and i want to begin
with yuno actually he disappeared very
early on in the first dark and i wasn't
quite expecting to see him again so soon
but it was a very pleasant surprise for
the main rival character dude he's
extraordinarily likable and i think i
said something along these lines in the
last video but the quiet cool looking
super talented teenager is very rarely a
character that is meant to be
immediately likable usually they're
incredibly arrogant need to have some
sort of sense smacked into them quite
physically by some punching or something
but probably one of my favorite moments
of this arc was when yuna was talking to
klaus and even issuing him with a
warning not to underestimate astor
which is nothing new he did do similar
things in the previous arc but it's
still satisfying to see the undeniably
most talented person present going no
you don't understand make sure to watch
out for that protagonist i like the
feeling of respect
there plus seeing you know's wind magic
is always a pleasure of all of the
brands introduced so far i think i like
this one the best there's just something
so beautifully sharp about how the wind
magic is drawn like it's all innate but
it also exudes power unlike say the
plant magic which is very ornate but
also very docile or the lightning magic
which was powerful but not
hugely visually appealing to me and just
while we're on the topic of magic this
arc gave me what i was desperately
craving from the previous which was a
vague explanation of the magic system in
black clover it confirmed that mages
require mana which
yeah sure it might seem like an
incredibly obvious thing to say but i
don't recall it being mentioned at all
previously so it's just good to confirm
that rather than assume the thing that
excites me most though is this diagram
that shows us all of the different magic
possibilities which are based on the
four elements and even mixing them
together like how for example missed
magic sits in between water and wind i
live for stuff like this when it comes
to magic i crave rules and structure
because it's so easy to get lost in
poorly created systems i also really
like that a decision was made not to
reveal every magic type immediately
there's a lot of question marks on this
diagram and it makes me want to keep
reading to discover what they all are it
creates nice intrigue and also you need
the structure of rules in order to
enhance the drama when you decide to
break said rules which actually happens
in this very arc with our main
antagonist
mars and may i just say that both mars
and lotus are roughly
1 billion times better than the
antagonist of the last arc who i still
only know as
ice magic man because i was never given
a reason to care about him whatsoever
mars and lotus are very different
starting with lotus he has a captivating
personality he's outwardly casual but
also wildly intelligent and highly
determined he also has the perfect magic
finity being smoked which suits his
character really well because i felt
like i could never get a solid grasp of
lotus he just seemed to put up shroud
after shroud and i didn't really feel
like i knew who he was until the end of
the arc whereas almost every other
character we've met in the series thus
far has given me a strong first
impression that hasn't been subverted as
of yet what i really liked was seeing
lotus's little character info page and
discovering that his likes were his wife
and daughters in fact this page is
everything because we now know that he
is a dedicated family man and more than
likely just fighting to do what's best
for his family and i guess his kingdom
it makes this conflict significantly
more interesting because he doesn't seem
to be a bad guy in the traditional sense
in fact no one really seems to be a bad
guy in this arc everyone's just doing
what they think is the right thing that
needs to be done
and if anything after learning of the
stories behind our antagonists it really
does make me wonder if the clover
kingdom might be the real bad guys
overall then again i don't know because
there was some pretty sinister crap
going on with mars someone who i was
scared of being another stoic
characterless existence when he first
appeared but i was quite pleasantly
surprised
and he's also obviously who i was
referring to when i said the rules of
magic were introduced to be broken
as it is established that mages can only
generally have one affinity under their
command but
mars wields two mineral magic and fire
magic which is the result of a tragic
and horrific situation that i like to
call the azumi dilemma because that's
where i first experienced it and azumi
is basically a film with the premise of
raising a group of assassins since
childhood and then having their final
test before graduating being to kill
their best friend in the class
which i guess yes sorry spoilers for
like the first five minutes of azomi but
whatever it's not a new idea and i'm
sure that it was done long before azumi
but it's always effective and it's quite
heart-wrenching to read especially
because they play up the betrayal of
fans who immediately makes to kill mars
but then we reveal that she only did
that because she knew mars would not be
able to kill
her otherwise and it's just a mess of
raw emotion a really good mess that led
to him inheriting fan's magical ability
through i don't know vaguely defined
wizard science
so as cold and driven as mars is this
added some much needed warmth for the
character
and when we did see his split grimoire
which was very cool by the way it gave
me a good overall picture of who this
guy is and now i'm very excited to see
both mars and lotus in the future
because they're almost like protagonists
to me now in fact i'm kind of more
interested in their journey right now
than i am asters but once again that's
what i love about this arc there were no
bad guys strictly speaking no enemy of
the weak to bring down no evil for the
sake of evil guys showing up this was
all just pure character conflict it's
basically what happens when you take i
don't know how many people were in this
like eight protagonists with their own
stories and you put them together with a
common goal to fight over each and every
character in this arc is profoundly
likable by the end even klaus i should
say who started off as quiet the pompous
dick and then eventually profusely
apologized to both astor and yuno for
looking down on them that was a lovely
moment and as a result i want to see
more of klaus now and the broad idea
that connects all of these characters
with the possible exception of class i
guess
is family at the center of this family
idea are of course
astor and yuno who we have a brief
flashback of coming to the decision that
because neither of them had a family to
call their own then they would just
treat all of their friends as family
starting with each other which you know
that's nice but that also makes these to
the solar core that binds and enlightens
everyone else meanwhile noelle has a
fairly obvious family issue at hand
because we encounter mimosa who sounds
delicious and they have a bit of a noble
tiff before coming together at the end
as mentioned before lotus is revealed to
be a family man and by the end of the
arc mars has even made the first step
towards building that potential familial
connection with lotus but also the mars
and fauna story very much mirrors the
you know
aster situation two parentless children
brought together albeit in a much more
tragic manner and there is another super
obvious exploration of family as well
with luck and i've held off
talking about him because i think this
was by far the least satisfying part of
the arc for me
i do like luck quite a bit he has this
whimsical battle hungry nature which
gives me some serious nefapito from
hunter hunter vibes in fact there's even
a panel where he gives off those same
sort of pito crazy eyes but he has a
very hastily put together flashback
about his mother not appreciating him
until she discovered his one talent
which is fighting
so for reasons she incepts him with the
idea that he needs to keep fighting and
winning which is an interesting idea
actually this deeply rooted desire to
keep fighting into eternity simply to
earn the approval of a parent there's
really quite a lot you could do with
that however
in this arc lock's childhood trauma and
established way of life is flipped on
its head within like
two pages like it goes from luck
thinking to himself i have to keep
fighting and winning or else my mother
won't accept me and if i don't have my
mother then i am completely alone and
then like a page later he sees astor and
goes well you know except for that guy
he's my family now
and to me it feels extraordinary rushed
like i get that asta has his dramatic
semi-speech about luck being his friend
but even that seemed a bit rushed i mean
you met this guy like what a handful of
days ago maybe i think this might have
worked if it wasn't aster who led to
lock's realization like if it had been
another member of the black bulls whom
luck had been with for a much longer
period of time because in the end i just
have a really
difficult time buying that the screams
of a 15 year old child that you met a
couple of days ago can immediately break
through a lifetime of deeply rooted
psychosis but then again it is a shown
in series and not everything can be a
deep exploration
in the end though uh whatever luck story
is still fitting quite nicely with the
oval theme of the ark so it's forgivable
in regards to some important story
related
things though let's get back to astor
and yuno something that really intrigued
me at the beginning of this arc was the
idea of seeing this treasure hunt as
sort of a test race for the ultimate
goal of becoming the wizard king
something low-key with minimal stakes
but representative of a larger journey
to come
and i may and probably i'm just talking
complete crap here but i can see this
small arc evolving into a grander
representation astor and yuno go their
separate ways again
fight for newfound family friends and i
don't know they'll need to eventually
come together again to face some sort of
great opponent on a more
apocalyptic scale before being left to
decide amongst themselves which one will
become the wizard king in a similar
manner in which they needed to decide
which of them would get the dungeon
treasure which turned out to be both
yay oh and actually the treasure itself
was very very important by the way
because both astor and yuno seem to have
received their own individual upgrades
you know seems to have acquired some
sort of
insanely powerful scroll fairy question
mark which i guess now more or less
mirrors asda's bird familiar who has a
name now
it's nero i like it all hail nero but
astor also
appears to receive some sort of upgrade
in the form of a different sword which
very notably saw him
use magic for the first time i think and
i don't quite know how to feel about
this i guess it's heavily implied that
he borrowed the magic from noel and it
hasn't been elaborated on yet but
still i was very very keen on keeping
astor as a pure anti-magic existence so
we might be entering some very
shaky territory now where the power of
friendship allows astor some sort of
access to the magic of his comrades that
he's met
along the way which i don't know look i
should reserve judgement until there's a
solid explanation but the whole thing
made me feel a bit iffy
as did our brief glimpse of golden dawn
leader man if he's not some sort of
grand enemy then well done
tabitha for putting up this good front
because he's just so
damn nefarious like when he's thinking
about yuno and going yes we need him to
grow stronger
and it's just one of those things that
reinforces my previous thought about the
real bad guys or maybe they're not the
neighboring nations and maybe
it's the pinnacle of the clover kingdom
itself and it's a bit harder to tell in
regards to the wizard king who has now
taken a much more active interest in
astor which is
very quick it's chapter 11 and already
senpai has noticed astor which is
something else i don't necessarily like
but it is still too early to judge all
in all though this arc was pretty
surprisingly great after the first
chapter or two i thought it would be a
stock standard action piece that was
designed to do very little but provide
fights and harp on about friendship in
the way that shannon often does but it
accomplished a fairly incredible amount
actually it introduced and built
five new characters all of which i am
very keen to follow which is not an easy
task to accomplish in 11 chapters and i
suppose as a result at least one of
those characters does feel quite rushed
to me obviously being locked and maybe
mimosa i didn't talk much about her but
there wasn't that much to say to be
honest but the others were given quite a
perfect amount of time and space to
develop and overall it was just
really good super tight and i think i'm
looking forward to reading more but that
pretty much does it for this blind
review of the dungeon exploration arc
and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for small black clover
content then please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for very maybe
regular black clover goodness delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time